what up you guys
it's another stormy afternoon it's
always storming when we do these what
the [ __ ] man i don't know [ __ ]
florida we're in florida's monsoon
monsoon season yeah it's uh you know it
rains almost every day florida and
summer time so if you hear like weird
noises in the back that's what that is
that's uh
that's thunder big storm coming yeah
all right so the movie we're talking
about today was the one that again won
the patreon poll
this is the 1980 canadian slasher flick
terror train yeah i saw it when it came
out
i saw it in 1980 really yeah when you
were what 11 years old
yeah i can't believe i was that young at
the time i felt like i was a little bit
older
yeah but i think they played it on cable
in california
maybe maybe about a year i might have
been 12.
yeah because i kind of a year i kind of
feel like i saw this on cable like in
the early 80s
right i might have been 12 13 something
but it was new to me at the time
and um i loved it it scared me
even though seeing it now it's a slasher
without any slashing
it's not really all that bloody i mean
until the end
it gets like a lot more violent like in
the third act but even a lot of the
a lot of the kills are kind of like
off-screen or they're not real splashy
yeah what i remembered about it is uh as
a kid i remembered a lot of the scenes
seen it again i was like yeah especially
when she was at the end when she was
locked in the damn cage
yeah and the bad guy was sitting there
and then the reveal
about who it is i was like oh yeah yeah
i forgot about that
um there's some gender-bended [ __ ] going
on in it
and uh it was funny because i was i
don't want well [ __ ] i spoiled it it's
old well yeah it's from 1980 it's like
you know what i mean
turns out it turns out you know the uh
the villain had disguised themselves as
a magician's assistant
and uh you know when i first saw her i
was like
man she looks [ __ ] good now it looks
like a dude though in the shoulders
he's got wide-ass shoulders well because
it was a dude
well he wasn't he wasn't that the whole
time he was the because he
wore other costumes yeah it wore a bunch
of costumes which i thought was like a
really good
kind of a unique premise you don't see
that in a lot of slashers yeah but he
was young and they selected him for
you know somebody who could who could do
drag and be convincing you know
the fun fact i'm not sure if this is
true or not but i watched like a bunch
of different uh you know i read a bunch
of different stuff about this and i
watched a bunch of other reviews of it
apparently that guy that plays kenny
who's the killer which
you know like i said spoiler alert um
they don't really make a big secret of
that i have to say
um he actually did not um
audition for this role he actually came
with a friend who was auditioning
okay and then they looked at him and
said hey yeah you want to be in the
movie you're right and he was like okay
yeah so he didn't actually go there
that's what i heard so so he was just he
didn't try out
because he happened to look he had like
a certain he's actually a cool looking
dude i thought
he looked kind he could look kind of
like a [ __ ] goth rock
singer he did actually you would expect
him to be yeah and i kind of like when
they had
you know the that end scene where him
and jamie lee curtis are kind of like
you know
interacting and he had that great voice
i wonder is that really his voice they
overdone i don't know that's [ __ ]
crazy
but yeah so this was actually the
directorial debut of roger spadiswood
who would go on later to do he did
turner and hooch
he did uh air america he did one of the
bond movies i think it was uh tomorrow
never dies
okay so yeah so this was his first movie
and
this is like i said this is 1980 it's
canadian
and basically what they wanted to do
was halloween on a train that's how they
pitched it
um and the fact that they actually got
jamie lee curtis to be in this he was
also in prom night which was another
canadian uh slasher and i think it came
out the same year as this
so they actually got her in it and they
got david
[ __ ] copperfield david [ __ ]
copperfield
when he showed him i was like no is that
him said yeah that is him i forgot that
he was in it
david copperfield was in and uh if you
knew anything
you knew the culture of the time david
copperfield was the magician that your
mom and all your ants were all lusting
over
all right he was like a [ __ ]
heartthrob back in the day he's pretty
young in this
yeah i don't know if he was super super
famous yeah
in 1980 i can't really remember he was
age
he was huge because i remember seeing
like a lot of his shows on tv but i
think that was more like mid to late 80s
it was huge at least in california i
mean you know he was hanging out at the
magic castle and [ __ ] so he was well
known in california
yeah because like i said he's pretty
young in this now i think
he's been in other movies but i think
this is the only movie that he was ever
in where he wasn't playing himself
but they don't name him in the movie
he's just called the magician
and they kind of put him in there to one
like do his act when there was like not
much going on in the movie which i
thought was kind of neat
but also to act as sort of like a red
herring like oh maybe he's the killer i
was like wouldn't that that would have
been really funny if they'd made david
copperfield the killer but
no it was the assistant it well yeah and
it was the assistant who was but but
like i said this is almost kind of like
it they try to set it up like it's a
murder mystery like oh it could be
any number of these other people but
because they spent so much time
in the opening scene establishing kenny
you know the dork as having a really
good motive
for revenge yeah i really don't think
there's any
you know even though they kind of try to
make half-hearted attempts it's like oh
maybe it's this guy or maybe it's that
person
yeah you know there's really no saying
maybe kenny's a [ __ ]
red herring too you know that was kind
of the idea i kind of thought they were
trying to make it seem like
kenny had grown up into david
copperfield even though it had only been
three years and i'm like and they don't
look anything the same
well because they were trying to set up
that kenny was like into magic as well
and they even make a thing like in the
script like oh i didn't know he was into
magic
and i was like are you trying to make me
think that like kenny grew into david
copperfield in three years what the [ __ ]
did he have some kind of like body
switching
they don't look anything alike yeah but
yeah so there was that whole thing so
so basically what you have here oh and
vanity is in this too yeah i forgot
about it like briefly she's not
vanity yeah very young vanity we didn't
realize she had she died like a few
years back
back in 2016. yeah because i was like
looking at her and she had like a really
cool costume because everybody has
costumes on even though it's new years i
don't really get it but whatever
and um yeah it didn't make sense that
they were doing new year's costumes but
you don't wear costumes in new york yeah
is that a thing
it's like i know sometimes people wear
like goofy hats
and like have horns and stuff but it's
like i never heard of anybody having
like costume parties
yeah they were dressed like it was
halloween i was watching uh dr wolfila
which i love dr wolfila if you guys have
never
seen that channel and he did like a
really really funny
breakdown of this and uh he was
basically saying the same thing he's
like
he's his uh his theory was that when
they first wrote the movie
they didn't they couldn't decide like
what holiday they were going to say so
we'll
put all this other kind of stuff in here
and we could just make it whatever
holiday we want should have been
halloween
yeah but it's like they didn't want to
do another thing with halloween because
it's like we wanted this to be halloween
like you know like that but we wanted to
be on our train because like i said when
halloween came out in 1978
um you know and it cost however like it
cost under a million dollars to make and
it made like all the money in the world
so that really jump started the whole
slasher thing so there were just so many
[ __ ] slasher movies that came i mean
1980 there was like
[ __ ] ton of this one is just college
kids getting ready to graduate they're
on a damn train they're med students
yeah i think they're pre-med or yeah i
think they're pre-med it doesn't really
matter
they're medical but they're on this
private
steam train yeah it's like an excursion
train
yeah it just goes around this track and
it doesn't go anywhere it just comes
back
yeah it doesn't really matter it's like
a party train yeah maybe there's
something like that in canada but i
don't think there's anything like that
in the united states well there might be
i can see the appeal of it if they do it
kind of um you know would be awesome if
they did like kind of an old
steam train and then they did like a
murder mystery dinner like on there and
it was like a special
that would be cool i would do that
trains carry cargo
you know they have amtrak they do carry
some passengers here in the united
states but
all your all your rail lines they're
either in use or they're torn up
you know yeah they don't just have
random tourists
list let's just go in a circle train
they don't have that
let's go with a circle yeah let's go on
a circle trim well it's funny too
because there's kind of there's kind of
some stuff
in this movie and i guess it's supposed
to be kind of like character development
or like you know
local color or whatever where they talk
about the um the conductor he's probably
the best character in this
uh him and uh jamie lee curtis's
character and he's the conductor and he
kind of talks about i think he's played
by um
ben johnson i think is that actually
he's always in western yeah he's yeah
he's like a big
yeah he's known for a lot of westerns
and he's actually like a real like
nice like evocular type of character and
there's like a couple of scenes where
he's talking to the other dudes on the
train
like about um how trains are on the way
out and he's like he's you know yeah you
can keep working on these crappy trains
i'm gonna be on the concord and all this
other kind of stuff yeah and then it's
just like i don't know it's just like a
really weird thing to put
in the in the movie trains we're going
out
well yeah they were but it's just like
funny that they spent a lot of time uh
kind of establishing that and also
establishing that the conductor also had
a side business
uh selling rvs and it wasn't doing that
well and that's why he had to like
conduct this
yeah this [ __ ] side gig he was one of
the better written characters
out of the out of the movie i liked him
yeah i did as well
yeah he's kind of like uh he plays the
role he's the conductor
but in this movie they're trapped on
this train
murders are taking place and
there's no way to get you might as well
just go through the circuit that's the
fastest way back yeah they do stop at
some point and then everybody gets off
but it's like freezing cold
and you know there's nowhere for them to
go so it's kind of
they have to have an explanation of why
you're trapped on a train
yeah and uh while they're on the train
he's kind of acting
like uh his role is kind of is pretty
much like the town
sheriff in a western yeah pretty much
same role
and he the guy kind of plays those roles
anyway so
he's a natural for it you know just kind
of a down to earth
nice guy who's old probably what 60 60
something maybe yeah
and you know he's got deputies but those
are just the other train
train car guys yeah you know and they're
trying to keep order and
deal with the damn emergency kind of
almost like
it has an element of like a disaster
film in terms of like you know
it's air disaster now that you've uh now
you're bringing that up
it's kind of like something that would
happen on an airplane you know what i
mean talking to the control tower
and we don't know what's going on that
kind of how do we get out of this mess
that kind of [ __ ] well and i like too
that at first
like when the murders start happening
like we know that there's a serial
killer on board because
honestly one of the dorky characters at
first who i'm actually glad was like the
first one that they bumped off because
he was super annoying
but um because he's like oh i'm the
comic relief character and i'm talking
to a sex doll and oh
my the sex doll won't even kiss me
because she's a lesbian and i'm like
that's yes
so before they even get on the train
that dude gets run through with a sword
everybody thinks it's a joke and then
the killer comes and takes that kid's
costume and gets on the train so
everybody thinks
and so i think that's one of the things
that actually distinguishes this movie
because like i said it's a pretty like
by the numbers
uh slasher movie and if you like those
if you like jamie lee curtis
um you know it's kind of middle of the
road as far as that goes
but it does have some stuff in it that
you didn't really see a lot
and one of the best things i think was
that the killer when
every time he killed somebody he would
take their costume
so he could kind of move around on the
because it was like a [ __ ] ton of like
medical students and they all had
costumes on he's changing identities
yeah so he could move around like
freely and everybody just said oh it's
you know what's his face you know
because
that was the costume that he had on so i
thought that was like a pretty clever
uh thing that you didn't see in a lot of
slashers
she just called it a slasher it is a
slasher without a whole hell of a lot of
slack yeah it's not real gory
not very gory you don't even really see
any like
i didn't realize how much how much of it
is
implication it just implies that a
person's throat is cut it doesn't
actually show it
i mean you mostly just see the aftermath
yeah you'll see the aftermath that's
about it
and watching it i was remembering how
much i liked it as a kid because i
didn't have to like cringe every time
somebody's gonna get killed
because i was more confident that i
wouldn't actually see a whole lot
yeah because uh yeah because and really
i was judging it against friday the 13th
part one i think and uh that wasn't as
gory as you remember it
either really yeah we brought that up
before i was like actually i hadn't seen
it for
probably 20 years when we watched it
again i'm like wow that was like hardly
anything not a whole lot in it it's just
a lot of it was implication
and bodies hanging but they weren't you
know when you're a kid and you're just
new to this kind of imagery you know
as of the times you know the 80s very
early 80s
that was mind blowing [ __ ] yeah wow
it was kind of subversive you know you
really weren't supposed to be watching
it so society didn't approve of this
[ __ ]
these weren't good these weren't
respectable movies yeah i mean it's not
like like i said it's not like nowadays
where they're just like show somebody
with a hammer like smashing somebody's
face like in loving close-up you know
whatever yeah seeing it whatever but
yeah so that's one thing i mean i think
probably the goriest thing that happens
is like when that douchebag gets killed
at the end that douchebag the guy that
plays doc in this
he was in uh what do you call it he was
in um
[ __ ] man what's that [ __ ] movie
called i mean i just totally like lost
my
[ __ ] train of thought die hard die
hard he was in die hard i think he's one
of the bad guys
and he played a douche bag in that one
too he just has this really douchey
punchable face i guess that's why he
always got those kind of rolls
um but when he gets killed toward the
end of the movie
you don't see him get killed but then
somebody finds his body and he's been
beheaded and like his head rolls out and
stuff that's probably the glorious [ __ ]
that happens
but yeah so other than that like the
guys switching
um you know costumes i liked that i also
liked
that at first like the conductor finds
the first
uh murdered person who's like a guy who
was dressed up like was he supposed to
be a snake or a lizard or
he kind of yeah it kind of looked like a
sleaze deck or the gorn
something like that so it was like a
full body costume too so he committed
and so he's in the bathroom and he gets
killed like the killer kills him by like
smashing his head into the mirror and
he's laying there's like
blood all over now the conductor goes
into the bathroom and he sees the guy
dead and he sees blood all over
now he's initially he just thinks it's
an accident like the guy was drunk and
just like fell into the mirror
or some kind of [ __ ] and that killed him
so he doesn't want to alarm all the
other party guests
so he's like talking to the other guys
it's like should we tell everybody what
should we do and it's like you know
we'll just radio ahead or blah blah blah
but then i liked that when he went back
later he's like when he says to the
other guy come here i got to show you
this
when he goes back into the bathroom the
guy is still laying there
in the lizard suit but now all the blood
is gone
and the guy is still alive like he
starts moving around like oh i'm so
drunk because the killer
has cleaned up the blood and gotten into
that dude's costume
they never show what he did with the
other body though
how he got it out of the bathroom with
anybody seeing him or anything like that
so a lot of stuff is kind of going on
behind
the scenes i guess it didn't matter it
just it
was a movie of its time they're just
saying yeah he threw it out the window
he threw it
out of the train and cleaned up you know
then that's probably what would have
happened yeah
now they did there wasn't enough time if
you ask me well yeah but like i said
it's
you know i guess i guess it's a movie so
i wasn't really all that worried about
it although i did kind of be like
um i'm like yeah how did he get rid of
that because these that's kind of where
all the sleeper car
[ __ ] was and there was like bathroom so
you'd think that you were dragging this
big because the dude that he killed was
like kind of big what i liked about it
was the tone of the movie and the
visuals
um it was 80s interiors and it was in a
train
interior it kind of gives it it's shot
the
shot the shooting in the film the film
quality is kind of grainy
all right but there's something kind of
cool and retro about it
it had a pretty good score for for the
budget
and it was just kind of classic 80s
horror type
score going on in the back um
i just liked it the tone maybe it's
because it was just you know
nostalgia or whatever but this kind of
tone is actually making a comeback
it is yeah so it's kind of come back
around in style really
to see movies like this yeah it's cool
i mean fun fact they actually did shoot
this on an actual train
uh the train was moving when they were
shooting it because they were like hey
might as well like train moves so we
want to get that
motion to make it look realistic uh also
fun fact the guy that was a
cinematographer on this
same cinematographer as the shining okay
and barry lyndon
uh so a couple he worked with kubrick a
lot so that's why a lot of the shots
because when like a couple of the shots
particularly like the long shots of some
of the train cars and they have like
really dramatic lighting and stuff
i was just like oh that's a nice shot
that's so that's why i was like it was
somebody that knew what they were doing
but what they had to do though was they
used an actual train which must have
been a [ __ ] nightmare to film
because they're kind of confined you
know just because there's like a million
[ __ ] actors in this
and then there's like the crew and
everything they had to change out all
the lighting
in the train because the obviously the
train it wasn't bright enough
uh you know for the film so they had to
go in there and like rewire the train so
they could get like all the bright light
in there
but it is actually shot in a real uh
train so
like i said what you have at the because
what you have at the beginning
is there's like a little bit of a
prequel which is like three years
earlier type of thing
and they show why the killer
decided he was gonna kill all these
[ __ ] so what they do to him
and this is pretty shitty i mean i can't
blame the kid i gotta say
so they're all medical students like i
said and this one is kind of like a
scrawny dork
with yellow uh underwear which is a
little upsetting
which you get to see so you know that's
something to look forward to
but yeah so they they do a prank where i
guess all their pledges
um you know you're supposed to get laid
and then you can take the beanie off or
whatever i don't do frat things
but um so they get jamie lee curtis's
character who i think her name is alana
and they get her to like lure him into
this
room like with the promise of getting
laid
and then she kind of like sits behind
this thing and like
talks to him and they have this all like
shadowy thing on the bed and everything
then it turns out he gets all up on the
on the bed with the
who he thinks is jamie lee curtis except
it's a corpse
yeah and it's in all like pieces and
stitched together corpse
yes so funny got it from the medical lab
med students
they're sociopaths well they said you
have to get used to this if you want to
be
you know in the medical field you know
that [ __ ] dude's
handing out dead hands to people and
[ __ ] yeah so it was just part of their
business
but yeah so yeah so that uh
understandably
like upset kenny and then he started now
see i don't know if he just started
spinning around because he was spinning
around or if he got caught
in the ceiling that caught the ceiling
fan okay he got caught the ceiling what
it looked like
um and then after that you find out like
they jump ahead three years and you find
out that that kid like from the trauma
he got sent to like a
you know mental hospital or whatever so
so as i said since you
know since they spent so much time like
setting that up you know that kenny's
the killer
you just don't know where he is you
don't know where he is because the
costumes keep changing and like i said i
totally did not remember
um the him being the magician's
assistant the whole time because like i
said they're trying to set it up like
david copperfield
is the killer because there's a couple
lines in there where the conductor says
wait you know i didn't think anybody
hired a magician so you're thinking
david copperfield just like poofed onto
the train and
decided he was gonna kill everybody yeah
but david copperfield gets killed too
but in his own trunk with his own swords
the
the movie kind of has uh late 70s
early 80s sexuality to it which is tacky
and then i like it
it's tacky and i like it yeah the girls
are kind of [ __ ]
there is something the boys are also
very [ __ ]
they're trying they're letting you know
that clothes will come off there is
you're going man take that off they do
give you some payoff it's
there's some brief titties yeah there
wasn't it really wasn't enough nudity i
don't think
and uh probably would have been a
complaint of mine back when i was 12 too
i was like nah there should have been
some more news yeah there was there was
one tit shout out
yeah yeah there should have been some
more yeah because it promised a whole
lot more
and it didn't it but it was okay you
know i mean it's just
that was the movies of the time yeah
yeah you felt like something bad was
going to happen any minute
you thought it was gonna turn into porn
because they looked like four stars
yeah a lot of them did it yeah it was
just kind of like it's hard it's it's
just kind of this sort of sleazy
yeah you had to grow it you had to grow
up during that time to understand it
and a lot of this probably didn't when
you notice it probably
yeah probably not yeah it's just i kind
of feel like a lot of this but probably
like the first two thirds of it yeah
there's murders like i said you don't
really
see them you sometimes you see the
aftermath but it's nothing super gory
so most of that is just kind of like
meandering there's like some
you know partying there's a lot of magic
jokes dave i mean david copperfield gets
to do like
seriously a whole like magic game he's
so [ __ ] he's so [ __ ] smooth man
yeah he's like dude throwing coins
although you know it does kind of
watching that [ __ ] did kind of remind me
of how tacky how kind of cheesy
magic was it it was very cheesy but it's
fun cheesy even some of the peop even
like a couple of the characters in the
movies like man [ __ ] magic is [ __ ]
late
[Laughter]
especially like on the [ __ ] he had
the thing with the car
that was like so much that [ __ ] and then
he's like flirting with jamie lee curtis
like with the rose and
do you believe in magic like with the
roads and everything oh my god i lost my
i laughed my ass
that [ __ ] eventually [ __ ] evolved in
the tacky ass chris angel and [ __ ]
pretending to be run over by
steamrollers
you're like man come on this is special
effects you're on tv
man you know this is a setup
yeah it's not quite as impressive like
when you uh don't see it in person
because you they could be doing anything
the last magician that i liked
would have been david blaine yeah
because he at least did some daredevil
type [ __ ] like
go into a sphere of water just for like
what a week
nearly killed him [ __ ] his kidneys up
yeah or just
standing there on top of a damn pole
[ __ ] stories i did that [ __ ] for what
how long about three or four days god it
was a long time yeah just standing
yeah no thanks yeah glad you're doing it
because i'm not gonna you know he had a
colostomy bag or something
well i hope so what's he doing just
pooping in his drawers gross
he must have been fully fully hydrated
and just had a catheter in [ __ ]
you imagine having to go up there and
get his ass down from there he must have
smelled so bad
yeah nobody thinks about that do they it
was a trick
he was prepared to be up there for a
while i kind of i feel like
you imagine he couldn't sleep if it was
me i would just like go
to do and then i'd go up there and
everything and then i'd have like a you
know
an extremely life like wax figure of me
and then just go poop and put that up
there and
i'm gonna go home and go sleep on my
couch and i'm so trapped in a [ __ ]
cube of ice you could yeah remember that
one too
just on the [ __ ] street in new york i
think it was in the [ __ ] heist
well so the whole time that we were
watching terror train and like uh david
copperfield was doing the [ __ ] i was
like trying to think of like
you know tricks that he could do to
because
for a second it almost looked like like
one trick that he did
he kind of like looked like woo he
disappeared and i thought that was
pretty cool but then like the lights
just went out slightly hand tricks you
know what i mean it's mostly that like
you know the cigarette through the
quarter
gag and all this which i had when i was
a kid yeah there's got to be a hole in
there must be a hidden trap door in
there it's something like that
it's just made so well you can't see the
crack yeah yeah but yeah
it was mostly card tricks and then he
did that one trick where
um where he had vanity like cover him up
with a sheet
and then she pulled the sheet and then
he was gone and then he like popped up
so that was probably the most impressive
one
um but you know you'd think he would
have made the killer disappear but no
he got murdered yeah he got murdered
like in his [ __ ] box
but i just thought it was so funny that
they were trying to set it up the whole
time like he was the killer when
everybody like i said everybody knows
who the killer is it's kenny why did
they set it up but like i said you just
didn't know where kenny was because he
was always in a different thing
and i did not yeah it was kind of like
that and i totally did not
well i wasn't really paying attention to
the assistant which i guess was you know
that was that was a good thing that they
did in the movie
was they had enough uh you know sort of
distraction
from the assistant like the magician's
assistant that you didn't
like necessarily think that that was
kenny like sometimes
so when he pulled the wig off at the end
like with it you know i was just kind of
like oh [ __ ] okay i gotcha
and uh also i liked like i said the last
third is probably the best
like where he's chasing you know where
he kills the douchebag
and then like with the head and
everything and then he's chasing jamie
lee curtis through the train and she's
like in the cage and
poking him with the [ __ ] uh you know
that spike thing that you put all the
notes on
which he's like poking him in that she's
all covered with blood and he's trying
to strangle her and [ __ ]
and then the [ __ ] conductor comes in
and like whacks him in the side of the
head with a shovel and like knocks him
off the train and then he falls off the
[ __ ] bridge and into the [ __ ] ice
and then the movie just ends yeah i like
that they just didn't even [ __ ] around
they're like yep he's dead
it's over well that was yeah there's a
climax yeah
resolved we don't need any further i
remember that ending when it happened
again i remembered as a kid and not not
only was his did his body fall the head
was
fall fell with him somehow he got
decapitated
that was a really sharp shovel i guess
yeah wasn't it because i feel like when
it hit it
i thought it was like a shoe hit so i
didn't know if it was his head or if it
was a shoe
oh okay so i guess he i guess that
conductor was like so badass that he
just knocked his head off with his head
off with the shovel pow
yeah and then you're just gonna sweep it
all off the train getting rid of the
trash there we go
although i felt kind of bad for kenny
because like i said they did they did
some like [ __ ] up pranks on him so
yeah
you can't really blame the kids he did
well like i said he was a good looking
he was a good looking dude
i can i can see how like when he came
into the auditioning thing and they were
just kind of like
that guy because he looks like a star
you know i mean like his face like he
really looks
like soon as you see me he looked like
he'd be the lead singer of like a really
cool goth band
like better looking than peter murphy
he'd have made a better peter yeah he
was
yeah he was a really good looking dude
and like i said if that was his real
voice he had like a cool voice as well
you don't really get to hear much of it
because he's like talking yeah he had
kind of a
in a way kind of a [ __ ] tough look
for
not being very not having a masculine
face he still kind of looks sinister
you'll see him if you watch the movie
yeah he's cool it could do and like i
said i don't even know if he was in
anything
uh after this but you know what i mean
but you know this is definitely worth
watching
if you like slashers of this era if you
like magic
if you like david copperfield and you
want to see david copperfield
uh on a train like doing like really
cheesy magic tricks and
flirting with jamie lee curtis um it's
kind of
hilarious uh then yeah definitely and of
course jimmy was looking hard as ever
she's looking cute she yeah she was
actually the best part of this her and
the conductor characters were my
favorite
yeah they basically carried the movie oh
yeah big time because
the rest of the characters are not super
likeable yeah and they're kind of
forgettable and you're just like yeah
generic jocks there's there's like three
generic jocks
yeah they were just like douchey frat
boys and you know so you were just kind
of happy to see him get killed
but yeah that's well that's how like a
lot of slashers
they were just dicks yeah they were just
sticks yeah so you know
no one felt bad yeah so so yeah uh it's
on
shutter we watched on shutter yeah i
think shutter just added it not too long
ago
and it might be on some other streaming
services too i'm not sure but if you
have shutter you can totally uh check it
out on there
so uh yeah if it's sounds like your kind
of thing
then go [ __ ] watch it or don't i
don't care no
just kidding all right we'll see you
guys on the next one
bye